we're happy Ashe went up yep sorry until
they went over you happy Ash Wednesday
people yep repent Bob Iger might have
stepped down a CEO of Disney there's a
rumble trailer out from Paramount
Pictures people in the comment section
still don't know that I haven't seen
Star Wars the Clone Wars and are getting
mad that I'm not covering the latest
season but more importantly there's a
trailer out for Saint mod called Ash
Wednesday from a 24 today I'm Greg this
is Erin Alexander what's up I've been
wondering this guy to come on the
channel for a long time he is a
wonderful poet actually someone with a
kind heart like his I was like well it's
perfect that we watch a horror movie
trailer together
you look really comfortable thank you
he's six foot eight so it's kind of hard
getting him in the frame awkward cherry
is just King today he adjusted it before
I got here to know we could be the same
place but guys Erin's a great guy follow
him on social media are you excited to
do your first reaction we usually talk
about like Marvel and DC and this
excited let's explore our Christianity
let's repent you don't know Christianity
do let's do this
[Music]
how long have you been doing this just
do for you what were you doing at the
hospital maybe leave
[Music]
that what made you leave oh my god Jesus
she looks like I could take that
defeated always
he's physically in me
which is the right day to wear my
daredevil beanie
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I saw the first trailer for this a
couple months ago and really sitting
like this is pure 8:24 kind of horror
movie it feels like very indie drama
with the psychological edge with a
horror movie trailer that makes it look
like it's gonna be a total scare fest
throughout but it never really ends up
that way the tones of them are this
really deliberately paced oppressive
insidious closing in on you fanatic
element to it and a lot of like really
spooky jumps scary kind of stuff truly
terrifying stuff usually occurs like
closer towards the end of the movie and
I've noticed like 8:24 a lot of times
we're like watching one of these movies
and then you're waiting a long time
before your liqueurs it's gonna really
get like really terrifying that
eventually what do you think of the
trailer man gave me a lot of spooky
vibes and I feel like it's gonna be
similar to what you're saying in the
sense that you're gonna be waiting there
for a long time I'm gonna be tricking
you and sort of giving you these like
these little tablets of spookiness along
the way before they finally hitch in
that finale you know some stuff that
really freaked me out was the the nails
in the the foot hole situation uh-uh
don't bring me back to a quiet place no
no I think that yeah I'll probably see
it not a horror guy but you know you
never get too much religious angst I
would love it if the twist is this is
actually God God is actually doing this
inside me because like the impression
that I'm getting is that it's a mislead
that this person believes this is God's
will that God wants them to sort of go
through with these things forget the the
religious terminology I'm looking for
here it's kind of that like
self-punishment stigmata kind of form
self-punishment but it's a way of like
deliverance to God like a full-on
religious discussion but with religious
Channel yeah we're religious Channel and
I know that's what does well and
obviously jokes about religion are
always great
what the vibe I'm getting is that it's
this person thing Scott this is God's
will but it's probably some satanic cult
thing that's going on and it's something
from the devil that's really taking hold
of her and possessing her so that's
usually what it is these right
situations they're always like thinking
it it's God and then sooner or later you
find out it's like the devil or like
that creepy uncle that like we haven't
seen in like seven years so it's always
of that kind of energy so that's why I
would like it if by the end you're like
oh this is God totally be different I
think I'd be surprising and I think I
would throw a lot of people off as far
as like these 8:24 trailers go what I
love about the way they do their
trailers is like the first trailer
definitely took its time a lot more got
a little bit more sense of the character
but I notice that whenever they do a
follow-up trailer that's something
shorter they really capitalize a lot on
their editing motifs it's like
hereditary it had like that tongue click
mid Samar had this like gasp effect and
this one has like the striking matches
effect I think what they do with their
trailers is really freaking smart and
then they usually open to a low cinema
score
I kind of get some mother vibes from me
I think Darren Aronofsky's mother has
some hereditary bags a little bit as
well of course
8:24 all horror moves from 8:24 feel
like ya guys are you guys going to
church today if you are repent in the
comments below my god the others were
[Laughter]
offering what did you grow up as pagan
oh really yeah
hard core sacrifices every every
Wednesday this is a great first
impression video I hope people watch the
other videos are we're talking about
like joker known solely judge because
you're like the nicest guy I know
jokes are totally gonna be misconstrued
great oh yeah we really knocked at the
park we should have just talked about
Bob Iger leaving the Disney CEO position
safe and talked about Jurassic world
Dominion but no we're doing this instead
where all hail the Hail Mary three times
okay
verification now why'd you think of the
trailer if you dare to follow Aaron on
social media yep